ce que je trouve fascinant et là je
serais d'accord mon interlocuteur c'est
la politisation qui a eu et une
politisation la jeu j'imagine que vous
serez d'accord de dire comment se
fait-il que à la seule publication à la
seule publication déjà d'un article en
dehors du scandale que représente cette
représente l'article lui-même qu'à la
seule publication il ya eu une réaction
si direct presque réactive de l' oms et
du gouvernement français mais je trouve
que là c'est pas sérieux du tout aux
critiques raout sur ces réactions
intempestives et là je crois que c'était
intempestif au sens du mot intempestifs
c'est à dire que c'était extrêmement
rapide comme s'il fallait tout de suite
là réagir réagir immédiatement ça c'est
le premier poids parce que là la
politisation elle est vraiment réel
elle est vraiment belle est le 2 le 2 le
deuxième point ces scandales il faut
quand même à paraître aujourd'hui parce
que et c'est au delà de la question de
la chloroquine au-delà de la question
polémique de raout les pour les contre
tous et toutes ces choses là font
apparaître qu'aujourd'hui la recherche
en médecine en particulier qu'il y a des
problèmes aujourd'hui dans la recherche
en médecine dans le bâtiment dire dans
les liens le financement des
laboratoires
imaginez en sens inverse quand même
juste une seconde ce qui se serait passé
on a vu ce qui s'est passé là quand
imaginer ce qui se serait passé si une
telle erreur de dire vraiment un tel
scandale était arrivé dans le cadre de
la gestion de crise des idées choix qu'a
pu faire en plus qu'a pu faire didier
rahout dans son nid à chenilles mais là
il serait littéralement crucifié
parce que là vraiment le vraiment mais
l'article l'article du l'an passé s'est
quasiment jamais arrivé chez pas je
parle sous votre contrôle
moi j'avais jamais vu en tout cas dans
le lancet qui avait déjà eu d'aidé mais
même le du du rédacteur en chef du
lancet qui avait déjà fait son
autocritique sur certains certains
articles
mais à ce point ce n'était jamais arrivé
c'est quand même une remise en cause de
la de la crédibilité du du journal
scientifique médical le plus prestigieux
au monde celui qui est supposé
représenter le plus de garanties
vous dites avec le new england journal
of medecine cas suivi c'est quand même
c'est quand même extraordinaire
[Musique]